vamos a suponer que que tengo un círculo
este es mi círculo entonces bueno ahí
quedó bien ok
este círculo como todos los demás tiene
un centro ahí está el centro del círculo
y digamos que tengo un arco en el
círculo ajá tengo este arco en el
círculo el cual este arco psuv tiende un
ángulo
entonces dibujo aquí este arco ahí quedó
bien ahora voy a tomar los extremos del
arco y de ahí voy a dibujar una línea
que va al centro del círculo entonces
este arco este arco verde psuv tiende al
ángulo digamos que este ángulo éste está
vamos a llamar este ángulo teta y muy
bien digamos ahora que el ángulo theta
es igual a dos radiales supongamos que
sabemos que el ángulo theta es igual a
dos radiales entonces mi pregunta para
ti es la siguiente
fracción de toda la circunferencia es
este arco ahora tal vez tú digas bueno
yo no conozco el radio de este círculo
entonces bueno como voy a resolver esto
para resolverlo simplemente hay que
recordar que es un radial así un arco
sub tiene un ángulo de dos radiales
entonces bueno eso quiere decir que el
arco por sí mismo mide dos radiales
entonces bueno si suponemos que el radio
de este de este círculo es r entonces
bueno si este ángulo mide dos radiales
eso quiere decir que el arco que se
tiende al ángulo este arco mide dos r
ajá entonces la longitud mide dos radios
dos r entonces a qué fracción de toda la
circunferencia equivale pues no sabemos
por geometría básica que la
circunferencia es igual
a 2 people el radio 2 people r
entonces a qué fracción equivale bueno
aquí tenemos dos eres sobre dos por r
y por r aquí se cancelan los los 22 y
también las erres entonces nos queda uno
sobre pi así que uno sobre pies la
fracción que estábamos buscando es la
respuesta correcta